fally la fin bonsoir alors y at il du
monde autour de vous venu rendre hommage
georges floyd oui il ya du monde autour
de moi plusieurs centaines de personnes
qui sont venues ici rendre hommage à
georges feuilles mais aussi à toutes les
victimes de violences policières et à
toutes les victimes de ce que les
personnes ici et s'il estime être du
racisme donc pas deux minutes de silence
comme sur la place de la concorde une
ambiance plutôt bon enfant avec beaucoup
de jeunes parmi les manifestants qui ont
fait le tour qui font le tour depuis
tout à l'heure en chantant en secondant
voilà à leurs revendications en
demandant plus de justice en disant
blacklight metter vous savez la vie des
noirs compter parmi les manifestants on
a parlé avec des jeunes qui nous ont dit
qu'ils avaient l'impression que
finalement la police exerçait finalement
des violences en toute impunité qu'il
fallait que ça cesse je propose de les
écouter
et si aujourd'hui on est là c'est pour
se battre contre les violences
policières là le silence de l'état sur
ces questions là et le meurtre de george
fleuve ça a vraiment été un élément
déclencheur et c'est pour l'heure c'est
pour ça que on est là parce que ça a été
filmé et que ça a fait réagir beaucoup
sur les réseaux sociaux les jeunes sur
plein de plate forme et je pense aussi
parce que c'était un meurtre
particulièrement horrible et est atroce
et je pense que là on s'est dit c'est
plus possible en fait il faut il faut
qu'on arrête et on peut pas et nous en
tant que blanc enfin pour la plupart en
tant que blanc privilégiés on s'est dit
on a une voix il faut qu'on s'en serve
pour la donner pour ce mouvement là quoi
c'est super important en fait pour nous
ça fait des années qu'on subit les mêmes
choses en fait ça fait des années qu'on
fait les choses ne changent pas ça nous
révolte et c'est vrai que moi je suis
découragée par rapport à moi je me dis
sans rien changer mais il ya là là par
exemple la mort de georges frêche a
déclenché quelque chose en moi encore
échu une mère de famille
ce défi et je veux qu'elle se sente
libre où qu'elle soit est en fait j'ai
envie de revendiquer sa je pense que
c'était la goutte d'eau qui a fait
déborder le vase en fait c'était parce
que c'est très violent
ça prend une fois que je vois une vidéo
carrément où j'ai besoin qu'on exécuter
quelqu'un devant nous en plus la
condescendance du policier qui a fait ça
qu'ils font je regarde la veine ce qui
se disait une façade arrière m'arriver
je retiens en noir devant
il va rien n'arrive est important aussi
d'être là aujourd'hui pour montrer que
que justement nous on n'accepte pas
toutes les violences policières qui les
ans qui ont lieu en france et partout
dans le monde
on sait très bien qu'en fait genre les
policiers se couvrent entre eux en fait
les violences policières c'est ancré en
fait de l'auto société et surtout les
langes policière qui a lieu tous les ans
même depuis des années en fait très peu
de gens sont très peu sombré en moi ya
pas de sont pas punis en fait si envie
de témoigner mais un soutien toutes les
personnes assises et qui ont qui sont
touchées par les violences policières en
fait parce que on s'en rend compte que
ces récurrences un problème est que ce
soit par la police ou d'autres systèmes
en fait le racisme il il est systémique
en français dans plein d'autres pays
dans le monde et on voit que c'est
vraiment ancrée dans notre société et
entendre personne blanche qui ont des
privilèges
c'est aussi à nous de faire bouger les
choses et de faire en sorte que bas que
nos frères et soeurs noires soient
soient entendues et qui reste pas dans
la souffrance en fait c'est pas normal
c'est juste pas normal et ça nous aussi
en tant que blanc de s'éduquer d'écouter
les expériences des autres et d'arrêter
de de faire les aveugles en fait
simplement comme je vous le disais donc
un mode de protestation pacifique
on voit les personnes faire le tour de
du champ de mars depuis tout à l'heure
dans la bonne humeur certains s'assoient
pour manger ensemble discuter boire un
verre et donc cette manifestation qui a
été interdite par la préfecture de
police se passe sans grande tension
entre les forces de l'ordre et les
manifestants on a vu des jeunes tenté de
forcer très brièvement un barrage
policier il ya eu quelques tensions à un
moment et puis finalement tout est
rentré dans l'ordre très très rapidement
cette manifestation se poursuit donc
dans le calme et on ne sait pas encore à
quelle heure elle va se terminer mais en
tout cas pour l'instant on peut dire ici
que tout va bien merci beaucoup elle il
a fait pour ces précisions lit la femme
ouzou en direct du champ de mars à paris